ما الذي تأمل
في تحقيقه بهذا الفيلم الوثائقي
بعد عام واحد ،
فنحن نأمل في تحقيق المساءلة
في حالتها ، فقد كانت هذه إحدى
أبرز الصحفيين في جيلها
وجهًا عرفه الناس
في جميع أنحاء العالم العربي والعالمي
الذي قُتل في  وضح النهار بينما كانت
ترتدي سترة واقية من الرصاص وخوذة وكلمة
الضغط واضحة للعيان في
منطقة لم يكن فيها تبادل لإطلاق النار في
الدقائق التي سبقت وأثناء
وقت مقتلها وتم تسجيل جزء كبير منه
بالفيديو وزملاؤها
هناك ليشاهدوها  الكل وبالرغم من ذلك
لم يكن هناك أي مساءلة في
قضيتها أه في العام الماضي حسناً وأنت
تعلم إذا لم نتمكن من
المساءلة في حالتها ما هي الفرصة التي
يملكها أي شخص في فلسطين
فهذا سؤال جيد ونحن جميعاً
نعلم  ما مدى صعوبة
تغطية الضفة الغربية المحتلة التي
تقول الجزيرة دائمًا الضفة الغربية المحتلة بشكل غير قانوني ، هذا ما
تقوله في روايتك وهو ما
أشير إليه هنا أريد
تشغيل سلسلة من المقاطع.  من الفيلم الوثائقي الخاص بك
أولاً
مقطع
لأنك قلت وأنت تظهر في
الشيء أنه لم يكن هناك تبادل لإطلاق النار في أي
وقت ،
لذلك هنا رجل يحاول أن ينقذها
لإنقاذها بعد أن سقطت
ويحاول سحبها بعيدًا وأنا فقط بحاجة
لقول أنه ربما يجد بعض الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون
هذا الأمر مزعجًا لأنه
من
مدريد ،
قفز شاب يدعى شريف من فوق
الحائط لمحاولة المساعدة
ولكنه كان أيضًا متحمسًا ،
فلماذا تعتقد أن هذا الجزء
من القصة كان مهمًا اشرح لنا
سيبدو المشاهدون جيدًا ، دعني أضع المشهد من أجلك
حتى ترتدي شادن وزملاؤها
وصفهم وهم يتجولون في
الشوارع نسمع دوي إطلاق نار حول
ست طلقات ، وذلك عندما تم
إطلاق النار على المنتج علي سامودي في كتفه بعد
ثماني ثوانٍ تقريبًا.  وعندما
نرى آخر لقطة لشيدين على قيد الحياة
رابضًا على شجرة
بعد ثماني ثوان ، هناك
انفجار آخر لإطلاق النار من سبع طلقات وأحد
تلك الطلقات المصيرية التي
تقتل شاد إنها مستلقية على
الأرض أه أنت تعرف بعد لحظات هذا أه
أحد المارة يحاول أحد المارة مساعدة
شادن وسحبها ثم يتم استهدافه مرة أخرى ،
وهذا يوضح أن هذا
لم يكن إطلاق نار خاطئ ، لقد كان
استهدافًا متعمدًا وأيضًا أظهرت أم
مجموعة الهندسة الجنائية
ومجموعة حقوق الإنسان الفلسطينية الحق
أن  تم إطلاق جميع الطلقات أه
فوق مستوى الكتف ما يسمونه
الطلقات القاتلة وتم إطلاقها على مسافة قريبة جدًا
من بعضها البعض وبالتالي
استنتجوا أيضًا أن هذا كان
استهدافًا متعمدًا ، فلنتحدث عن من فعل
ذلك ولماذا قامت الحكومة الإسرائيلية
على الفور  أصدروا بيانًا تعلمون أنهم
بدأوا بالقول إنه لم يكونوا هم
على الإطلاق ، فمن المحتمل أنهم
مسلحون فلسطينيون زعموا أنهم
موجودون في المنطقة الآن وأنتم ،
منظمة حقوق الإنسان الإسرائيلية البارزة جدًا وقد قاموا
بالكثير من التقارير التي فضحوا زيفها
حكومتهم وحسابات جيوشهم الخاصة ،
لذلك أريد أن أشغل هذا الجزء من
الفيلم الوثائقي الخاص بك حيث تجري
مقابلة مع مدير betsalem
من حيث مثل محاولة التحكم في
السرد ، يمكنك أن ترى كيف
تغيرت نسختهم  من المحتمل أن تكون
رصاصة فلسطينية من حيث كان يطلق النار
من هناك ، يمكنك أن ترى أنها في
الحائط
ولا توجد طريقة للوصول إلى شيرين.  ربما
كان الحق في ذلك هو أننا
تركنا شخصًا آخر من
المحتمل أن نكون نحن
وكل تغيير في هذه الرواية لم تكن
تعلم أن إسرائيل تطوعت به ،
لذلك هذا مثير للاهتمام حقًا واسمحوا لي
قبل أن أجعلك ترد فقط
قل أن تحقيق CNN الخاص وجد
تشير الدلائل إلى أن الرصاصة القاتلة
جاءت على الأرجح من موقع كان من
المعروف أن قوات الجيش الإسرائيلي كانت كذلك
ويشير نمط إطلاق النار إلى أن الرصاص
كان موجهًا بدلاً من رشه كان موجهًا
بدلاً من الرش
العشوائي ، لذا ما مدى أهمية
ذلك التحقيق الذي أجرته بيت سالم
وقد  الحكومة الإسرائيلية وأيضاً
الجيش الإسرائيلي أجرت تحقيقاً شفافاً
أه تعرفون
تحقيق شفاف ومستقل
أه لا أقصد أه لم يتم مقابلة أي من شهود العيان
في القضية أه
التحقيق لم يكن
شفافاً وكما رأينا في ذلك المقطع تحقيق
الجيش الإسرائيلي  تغير السرد
عدة مرات ، لذا في البداية
حاولوا إلقاء اللوم على مسلح فلسطيني أن
الادعاء هو في الواقع سخيف للغاية
مع الفيديو الذي نشروه ، وقد تم
فضحه بسهولة من قبل حيوان أليف سولومون
وقد أظهرنا ذلك أيضًا في مقالتنا
زعموا أن هناك
أدلة غير حاسمة ، ثم بعد
تقارير CNN من قبل صحيفة نيويورك تايمز من قبل
الواشنطن بوست من قبل وكالة أسوشيتيد برس
وتحت ضغط كبير في سبتمبر
أصدروا تقريرهم النهائي الذي قال إن
أم شيرين قُتلت على الأرجح على يد
جندي إسرائيلي ولكن ذلك  لقد تم القبض عليها
في تبادل لإطلاق النار ، فهم لا يشرحون كيف
توصلوا إلى تحديد Crossfire
وهذا الادعاء يتناقض مع
أدلة الفيديو من شهادة شهود العيان ولكي
نكون صادقين ، فأنت تعلم أن هذا
جزء من نمط طويل الأمد من قبل
الجيش الإسرائيلي  تقوم لجنة
حماية الصحفيين في الواقع
بإصدار تقرير الأسبوع المقبل حول
مقتل الصحفيين على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي منذ أكثر من عقدين ، حيث
ينظرون في 20 حالة منفصلة
لصحفيين قتلوا على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي ووجدوا نمطًا من
الرد الإسرائيلي مصممًا
للتهرب  المسؤولية ، لذا فإن حقيقة أن
تحقيق إسرائيل في مقتل
شيرين لم يسفر عن أي
مساءلة ، فليس من المفاجئ أن نقول
على أقل تقدير وكجزء من نمط من
الإفلات من العقاب ، وفي هذا الفيلم الوثائقي
تقول إنه لم تتم مقابلة أي من شهود العيان الرئيسيين مع
أي من زملائها.
ولا أحد من الذين تواجدوا بالفعل في
مكان الحادث لذلك اليوم بعد عام واحد كان هناك
اجتماع في إسرائيل أه
تعرفون أم
نقابة الصحافة الخارجية الإسرائيلية ونفتالي بينيت
الذي كان رئيس الوزراء في ذلك الوقت أه
سئل عن ذلك من قبل سي إن إن هذا  هو ما
يقوله اليوم بعد مرور عام على
حدوث أشياء سيئة ، يموت المدنيون
أحيانًا عن عمد وفي هذه الحالة
تحتاج إلى مقاضاة وأحيانًا لا يكون ذلك عن
عمد في هذه الحالة لا لا
أعتقد أنه إذا كانت هناك معركة مستمرة
وكان هناك أضرار جانبية
لا تتعمد حسنًا ثم لا ،
وإلا فأنت جيد ما
كنت ستفعله هو تكبيل أه كل
أيدي المقاتلين
ما هو رد فعلك على هذا الشريف
حسنًا ، أعني أنه يمكننا فقط إخراج
كلمته لم تكن هناك  هناك معركة مستمرة ، هناك
لقطات فيديو ، هناك 16 دقيقة
من الفيديو بواسطة أحد سكان جانين الذي
قام ببثه على Tick Tock
um والذي يوضح أنك تعرف كل تلك الدقائق التي
سبقت إطلاق النار هناك
لقطات من قناة الجزيرة وكذلك لم تكن هناك
معركة مستمرة في  كان المراسلون
يقفون في منطقة Clear Sight
للقافلة الإسرائيلية وبدأوا بالسير ببطء
في الشارع كما قال إذا كان
متعمدًا وهو في هذه الحالة
العديد من المنظمات وجدت
أنه كان متعمدًا أه يجب أن
تكون هناك محاكمة